hello and a very warm welcome indeed to
this latest edition of talking germany
the show where we do just that my guest
today is an actor and a politician
indeed he made headlines around the
world less than a year ago when he
became one of the first black members of
the german parliament and here he is in
person charles m huber
thank you very much for joining us today
charles here on talking to your
meditation wonderful great to have you
here now the story is this charles m
huber was born in munich he became a
national figure here in germany when for
over a decade he played a leading role
in a prime time crime series and last
september he won a seat in the bundestag
as a member of chancellor merkel's
conservatives
now
charles m hubert
i had the great pleasure last october of
of doing the commentary and the analysis
for the uh the opening session of
parliament to last autumn
and
the there was a moment where the camera
was actually trained on your face and i
turned to my colleague who was sitting
next to me and i said to him there's
charles m huber i wonder what is going
through his head today
and now i've got you right in front of
me so i'm going to ask you what was
going through your head
i think uh
nothing special i don't believe
i don't believe you for a minute yeah
i i or i simply don't remember but i
think you know if you have all the
election campaign and all that behind a
few
and then uh also you know you have to
organize all your office and all your
your structure your your working
infrastructure so you're happy you have
that halfways behind of you
and you don't think about how i'm not
this kind of person who says oh this is
great or whatsoever so if you talk about
what's typical for germany and
typical for my german the german part of
my character was at its work
let's do the job well
and that's it and nothing big
spectacular and i made it or whatsoever
no it's not a part of my education
that's an interesting spectator okay
that's an interesting insight into your
germanness but nevertheless i think
you're being a little bit disingenuous
because on on that day of course you
were you and karamba diyabi a social
democrat you were a christian democrat
you two gentlemen became the first two
black members of the bundestag now i'm
not quite sure how important that is or
not but certainly on that day
a lot was made of it in the
international press as well what did you
make of all the fuss that was made about
it you were in the spotlight yes but
that's what i told the international
press as you already said there was a
lot of interest from outside and people
were
asking about all these specific issues
of color and whatsoever so what i told
them is first of all it didn't play any
role in my election campaign
and it was not uh
it didn't play a role i mean i know the
chancellor for quite a while personally
you know the party for quite a while
personally so
the issue
in my campaign or a part of that will
depress made out of it on the local
level in darmstadt that's where i
started my candidacy was that i came
from bavaria
so
the thing is
color didn't matter that much
and you spoke before about my acting
career so
uh first of all now i'm not an actor
anymore so let don't don't let us rick's
we'll talk about the acting in a second
first the politics yeah
uh uh i mean the actor
thing
was more uh
discussed in german medias and
the parallels to arnold schwarzenegger
ronald reagan and all that that was an
issue but for us here in germany it was
more spectacular from outside than from
inside
so i suppose the next why did you go
into politics in the first place anyway
what was the reason for that decision to
break with the the acting career and to
go into politics
nowhere i think uh if you
think about what is the red line i'm now
all
i'm 57 and if you
think about your life and you try to
identify a red line so i think my red
line was always creativity
and
the
time where my political
consciousness
awoke it was the the
70s we were all
into politics we went to philosophy into
politics into religion
into a lot of things we tried to change
the world
nothing more nothing less
and uh
in in comparison to the youth uh
of uh
of our times uh
we were reading a lot we were reading
marx we were reading hildelin we were
reading freud and nietzsche and uh
also uh there was the vietnam war it was
the the colonial post-colonial area and
the emancipation movement of of blacks
and america and africa and all that and
so
we were all
i mean filmmakers were created more
creative
concerning uh
issues
and also more political movies so
politics and culture is not as far apart
as people think it is because culture is
also a vehicle as a platform for
politics as well
it's interesting you're sounding as
though you've you've sort of put
yourself sort of a little bit on the
left liberal spectrum where you're
coming from originally and that's not
where you've that's not where you are
now we'll talk about that journey in
just a second but just
very interesting for me is
you've got these two components in you
you've got these two skill sets or at
least you've got the skill set that you
acquired becoming an actor how important
or how useful were those skills or are
those skills for you now as a politician
well first of all
what may be uh
is a big advantage in terms of
self-marketing is that you're less
nervous if you're in the talk show like
yours or uh
if there's a camera
pulling up on you you're not there or
during your first speech
it was the first speech to the bonus
were you nervous
not at all no really it's my job you
know and if you're that's
the thing is as well that people say
sometimes they say no charles wait you
know it's different like stage i said
listen you don't know stage i know stage
if you step on the stage on the main
role and then you have a monologue and
then you have all the people sitting on
the first
line and they look at yourself uh let's
look what this guy from television how
he is on stage there we have this
this different
that's this two positions stage actor
television actor and i mean um both
and so but the people look if even if
always if they see somebody from a tv
series as well he may not do well on
stage so let's look what the guy
how the guy will perform and how he will
play this in that role so
for me it was nothing especially the
sixth the only problem i had to put my
that's what i wanted to say in the time
frame of six minutes that's an important
skill for us for a politician are
politicians actors
what is
i think what
both people have to do they have to
overcome
their
the natural emotional moment for for
example if you're influenced by by some
private uh things you know and then
you have to hold a speech you know you
cannot think about that what
does my wife
you know i had to argue with my wife or
how are my kids doing and all that and
this you have to forget about all that
if you have to speak to the people then
you have to to overcome you know the the
uh how you know your
natural feeling for the moment you have
to say this is my job i have to talk
about something different and i cannot
say yeah you know this isn't that i feel
don't feel so well you have to feel good
when you're talking i know exactly as a
journalist i know exactly what you are
talking about somebody else who has to
go on camera now
charles charles hubert it's interesting
that uh you grew up as we saw there you
spent the first nine years of your life
in the bavarian countryside of all
places in the bavarian countryside and
this is we're talking about the 1950s
the 1960s yeah and most people would
when they hear that story would say that
cannot have been easy yeah but you say
and i'm quoting i had an extremely happy
childhood then a very interesting word
that you use an unbroken childhood
what did you mean with that
i think if you
grow up at the countryside and
especially at the area where i grew up
you could be the way you are there was
nothing like people told you
it's hard for me to find
the
a word for that it's a certain kind of
freedom
and
that's what people don't think they
think if you go to a conservative level
a conservative area like this is a
conservative part of the world yeah
it's a very traditional part it's a
traditional and that what makes the
difference it's the difference between
conservative and the political sense
what people use it in a political sense
means conservative means the
non-acceptance it anticipates the
non-acceptance of new things
what is not true that was a new thing
and i was very well accepted and i felt
very well
of course i had the advantage that i had
a
warm and loving grandmother which really
loved me and this is my
the big love of my life and i uh
everything uh it must have been a big
surprise for her when your mother
brought you home of course as it were
at the beginning it's an incredible
story she came from munich and she said
look who i've got here
yeah she said actually she said my to my
grandmother you know my my child is
black
but then when i came and uh you know it
was snowing outside and i was when you
when i was
small it was a lot darker than i am now
and then i was dressed in a white woolen
dress and
i said oh no he's really black
it was unusual and of course when i came
there the people lined up in front of
the the the house of my grandmother said
we want to look we want to see what we
want to see we want to see the guy yeah
but it was uh
how can i say there was no
no no no judgment it was just it was new
they didn't say oh he's black he has to
be listeners and that and uh
people loved me i love the people i just
come back from uh
from
lower bavaria like you say in
english and uh i held a speech for the
day of labor day first of may
and i told them exactly the same story
because when the international press
came they said they they think you know
they asked me like you all would have
tortured me when i was a child and you
know i'm here and i'm
just as an example they i came back
to my
village about
when i came back i always met
individuals but once i tried to visit a
friend of mine his wife said hey charles
he is out in the guest house and check
him out over there i mean
over there
and then he was in the hall it was like
a
big hall you know and where they had all
the events you know from shoots and fine
and all that
and that the whole
village was there
and they were all waiting and i didn't
know that and i came in and
it was incredible so i shook hands with
everybody and
they had tears in the eyes the old
farmers
and all that and when i sat down when i
said hi to everybody i sat down
within five minutes i nearly fell asleep
and i felt so much as home as if i have
never left this this village it's
interesting i felt totally safe and
i mean that's uh yeah i'm from there
okay
the fact is though that you did leave
the village when you were nine years old
and you were taken to the big city you
were taken to munich the capital of
bavaria and that was very different what
you experienced there i felt very
strange
because sorry
first of all i spoke a
the dialect from the countryside
at one side and at the other side there
you were anonymous you were an anonymous
individual and then you had to explain
yourself let's say oh you don't look so
much german
who is your father from it then you have
to explain yourself
so
somehow i lost my identity by moving
into the city even that was painful it
was yeah
identity is an important thing you don't
want to lose it yeah yeah
i said i had to i had to explain my
identity but not my
african identity which i was not aware
of it enough uh by myself but my my
countryside identity
and about what i did
of course because then people started to
ask you know about the african side
that's where creativity started
you started acting i started acting i
said yes i'm a son of a big tribe chief
and all that and uh yeah and we had to
yeah we had to fight with lions snakes
and whatsoever because i'm son of a
tribe chief
and
they all believed that
and
then i
my my stepfather that was the reason why
i went to
munich because my mother married
my stepfather and so uh
he said listen
what are you what kind of rubbish are
you telling to the people i said what
said you a tribal
son of a tribal chief and he was sort of
jealous because he wanted to your
stepfather i'm remembering another
detail about you now your stepfather he
made up a story of his own about you he
made a story of his own and that's why
he had to forgive me because
he said to make
things a little bit easier for my mother
he said yeah and
yeah i brought him
from africa i was the one who took him
from africa he said he'd been a member
of the foreign legion and he said he
brought you back from algeria
but this was hurtful for you this was
confusing
you didn't know who you were
no i knew who i was where i knew who i
was and it was not confusing at all but
it was uh yeah i had to love about that
you know that we had a good
understanding this was a different
germany back then wasn't it yeah um
you there was this big breakthrough you
were one of the you one of the first
black people to be on german tv
for a national audience you played in
the series the the old fox and you
played a character called henry johnson
and
what was henry johnson's backstory who
was he
that's the back story was he was he came
from augsburg
and oxford is
80 kilometers from from munich and he
was uh yeah from oxford but as it was
from augsburg it was not visible
because the visible part of the uh of
the series was in munich was the the
the police station in munich so we both
came from augsburg the means the new
uh commissioner the new altar old fox
and he brought me from oxford yeah
just one more question on this on this
point the whole sense of identity and
the whole sense of race because there's
a
the feeling i'm getting is that you were
in a in a unique situation literally
unique because you were the only person
like you yourself and you came through
that experience and the world around you
has changed it's become a very different
world
nevertheless there was a moment in your
childhood where you you looked you
literally looked in the mirror
yeah and you said to yourself
i don't look like other folks
what did you do with that information
yeah that was a short moment because i
felt i felt i thought i felt like the
other folks
and i spoke like the other folks and so
and the people did not look at me like
i'm
not one of them
so there were of course some
sometimes they made a joke up on color
like they made a joke up on red hat
people on fat people and all and
you know everything was got a quality or
an and
something
some potential for a joke the lower
bavarians picked up you know and they
made a joke out of it and they made it
out of me my grandmother was very
annoyed you know after that when i was a
little big i
you know i
they give i cannot i don't have to have
slept you know the one or the other if
you said that
but uh still
in the summary of all that this is my
home i have this is my identity i'm a
member of the
um
club for uh
for
the the
keeping up the tradition of bavarian
language
was but the second language i learned in
my life was high german
that's interesting karamba diyabi for
example is one of the politicians in
germany who actually has a constituency
that he has to travel to and work in not
all politicians do because
because of the way the german system
works and you're one of those but that
doesn't mean that you don't work
incredibly hard the figure that we
usually hear for how hard people in the
german parliament work is
60 to 80 hours a week that sounds like a
huge workload
definitely it is but you always have
this is tradition is a tradition that
they always hammer the politicians and
say for not working and they get a lot
of money i think
we get that we are no
i don't want to start the discussion
again but we work very hard for the
money we get
and
it's not just it's not physical labor
but it has a physical effort and then
and uh
an impact to of course to your body when
you're uh concentrated in the
uh
over two weeks for example when we have
parliamentarian weeks for two weeks one
after the other
and you work 16 hours a day you get up
at six o'clock you go to bed at 11 then
you eat at 11 sometimes then your
stomach is full you don't sleep well and
then you're confronted with issues
discussions and all that a lot of issues
a lot of brain work and
so my committees are for example
development strategies
in foreign affairs economics energy
parliamentarian assembly of nato
so
then we get a lot of documents from
brussels in english 10 000 a year while
we give
2500 to brussels so you see brussels
have the
brussels has a great
strong impact on national uh
parliaments so a lot of work absolutely
you you you have four children yeah well
you're talking about the impact that
this has on on your mind and on your
body what about on your private life
your private life doesn't exist if
you're working 16 hours a day it exists
on
what's happened three more with my kids
because we are chatting and we calling
each other my kids are actually they had
the benefit that the time was they were
small
that was with them so i was not a
politician i was an act and a writer
and you didn't work quite as much back
then as you do now you can't have words
anything like that
i was located when i was shooting the
movie the after the series i was in
munich and the the shooting place was
munich location
but now they are over the youngest is 21
they're all studying in
german universities
economics and politics and informatics
and medicine and the one is now in
zambia as a social year
yeah yeah in zambia and we are always in
communication over
with the mobile stuff i have a good
relation to my kids because like i said
uh
before you know when they were small i
had time for them now it would be
hard it's a good combination yeah but
it's worked out that way yeah okay a
very serious point though and you just
touched on it there's something here in
germany that people call politik fed
rossen height
yeah which is that people
people
are or believe they are very
disillusioned
very disgruntled
with their politicians they say that
people like you
are lazy and opportunistic
and that must make you very angry you
just about touched on it there i could
see there's a feeling in you already as
a young parliamentarian you're thinking
this is not fair what they're saying
about me and us so you are interpreted a
little bit
different as i feel it
uh
as a person of public interest over a
long
period of time people have an opinion
about you how the way you are as a
person and i'm not this kind of person
or people say he says one day like this
but they're talking about the
politicians in general they're talking
about them those politicians yes and the
thing is
you have to advantage if you didn't grow
up with politics if you have
if you get into politics you have your
life experience already before on
different levels
and you bring in your life experience
and so you get more credibility if your
so-called queer einstein who comes from
another
professional level so i have this
advantage and i still have it but uh the
thing is of course in times of
globalization the the the fundament uh
that we have to deal with the global
economy is the same for everybody and
the
politique for us that we talk all the
same no we have the same tasks to handle
the task is called globalization and so
like
in former times where you have also two
different political global systems
communism and
non-communism a capitalist like the
communists say
so the discussion was different
we don't have this kind of discussions
anymore like we had this passionate
discussions
the one side accused the other side for
that and it was more
uh entertaining than it is now now we
just have to work we don't have to
entertain and we ask you sounds very
like your party leader angela merkel who
who who is very much who's
a pragmatic ideological politician but
there's an interesting thing about you
that you
i know i know that you weren't as a you
know you weren't an active member of the
social democrats but you were you were a
social democrat to begin with and now
you're a christian democrat a
conservative
let's go give me a give me a quick
explanation for the difference between
the two why you made that move based on
experience oh yeah
the thing is that the
the time where i was an actor
you know the whole art scene
has a stronger affinity to to to the
social democrats because the the
political communication is more on the
humanitarian level and so we
identified
we as
we actors we artists identified
ourselves more with the humanitarian
aspect
of life
and
whereas the conservatives were talking
about economics so uh
getting deeper into the political
issues you see that you cannot make
a
good politics in favor of a larger scale
of the population
covering up everybody if you don't if
the economics work bad so all the social
programs are based on the good uh
economical concept of a party or of a
government and that's why i choose
for
pragmatic for realistic reasons uh
the chris democrats you think you're a
member of the party that runs the
economy best of all
of course the opposition wouldn't
necessarily agree but that
point taken okay
charles that's an interesting project
it's all about it it's part of a wider
project for bringing 20 young farmers
from nigeria to to the eastern part of
germany for
for for training and get and and
finding out what they can about germany
that's what we saw it's very interesting
what do you make of the project do you
think it's a good idea
yeah i would say i would even like to
make it wider yeah because you have a
lot of refugees here
they stay here they have no
they don't they're not productive they
don't take uh pick up the language they
didn't pick they don't pick up any
professional skills
so while they're here
and
i think the process until you get
accepted as a refugee or not it takes a
couple of years
why don't uh wake can't we bring people
in the process of education learning the
language
later on to integrate if they are
accepted as refugees and having uh
job opportunities
as well and the ones who are not
accepted they can bring that back to
their country and make how can i say and
make a living on it and i think
charles you're you're you're beginning
to sound a little bit like somebody from
the greens or from the social democrats
again rather than somebody from your own
party
your own party has been criticized for
for not coming
not being progressive on precisely these
kind of issues no this is my personal
idea i invented yeah but you have to
talk to you have to talk to angela
merkel about this i already did but i
think we are in the professional uh
education this is a part of
our development uh strategies for
especially for african countries because
how can you build an economy if you
don't have qualified
people and investors need to find
qualified people for uh for getting
involved and engaged in the country so i
think this
may be mistaken we this is a a part a
program we follow since a long time
professional education i mean the the
the fundamental problem is that there
are so so so many people from africa and
elsewhere of course but somewhere afro
who would who would happily come and
live in germany who would happily come
and make a contribution because they're
very skilled people very dynamic people
concerning germany i'm sorry you're
right i was first thinking about the
perspective abroad a broad perspective
but here they have to say they have to
get into production they have to be
productive what can germany we're
talking here about what africans young
africans can perhaps learn from germany
and germans what can germans and germany
learn from africa
well first of all i think what young
people especially uh in africa what they
have they respect the parents they are
also conservative in that sense they
respect the parents they're polite to
their parents and sometimes okay they're
a little bit too polite because the
father says or the mother and that they
do what the parents say
but
what africans of course
youngsters have to
can learn in germany especially is
discipline very simple it's a long-term
thinking planning career planning and
all that but for that of course this is
easily said you need to
to have structures which uh a government
has to build up first so
i think it's discipline and the the the
willpower to achieve something the
willpower not to leave it up on god or
on somebody and say
it's destiny of course a part of life
can be destiny but you have to
how can i say you you have to you are
part of the destiny you can you can make
your own decisions you can mold your own
everybody is the driver of his own
destiny and that's what they i think
they they can learn in germany here and
we have a perfect system we have that's
what sometimes people say why you have
all these certificates and master and
the professional meister brief and all
that and this is a quality aspect and if
you have a paper like that
that you
you finished uh an education here on a
professional level you go somewhere else
you get also a credit uh for example
from a bank for for
uh
that you create your own business this
is possible and i think
this uh aspect has to be
communicated a little bit uh stronger
it's been interesting listening to you
talking about how you've grown up in
germany in your life in general in
germany and we've mentioned the fact
that you have four kids uh who have all
grown up in germany and are germans
how has their experience been different
and how is their experience of growing
up in germany being the same as
yours i think
my kids didn't have any problems here i
not just i think i know they did not
have first of all times had changed
dramatically and now you see the world
has become smaller people travel people
television communication internet and
you simply you see a lot of
if you walk through berlin you see
people from all over the world yeah and
at the other hand but that has changed
it's amazing how germany has when i
first got to know germany in the late
70s early 80s coming to germany
occasionally it was very much a
monocultural society now it is a
multicultural society it is a
multicultural society what
is important that is a multicultural
society on all social levels also on the
educational level
and uh
okay the kids my kids are all doing fine
they're all studying and
for different
german universities
the cultural
thing is as well of course i have
i don't put my african
descent aside and uh
say i also know my african side first
they had to discover it intellectually
then emotionally and then all together
and so they're in peace with themselves
they know the african side they know the
german side so they don't have this
identity problem but what they had to
think about while they should think
about mathematics or latin or whatsoever
wonderful okay on that happy note we're
going to move on to our quiz at the end
of the programme yeah
um
you were born carl heinz that's an
interesting fact that we haven't talked
about who's the real you karl hines or
charles
m nellis i was born as carl heinz but at
this time they they americanized already
a little bit the german language and it
was more
it fit it fitted just more to my to my
character if they
they call me charlie what they did at
the beginning and charlie they also
called the the the bavarians called
themselves carl they called them charlie
that was
half the very name it has english name
okay and in case you have been wondering
charles m huber m for muhammad
ali
that is your law i'm afraid uh on this
edition of talking german i'm very
grateful to charles m huber for joining
us today and sharing his impressions
about his life with us if you've enjoyed
his company as much as i have come back
next week bye-bye cheers
you